field of Psychiatry is not going to
change on its own because the field is
based on billion dollar Pharmaceuticals
my belief is that the metabolic theory
of mental illness will be highly
disruptive in the mental health field
and I am hoping to start a Grassroots
movement the only way we will help other
people suffering from chronic depression
anxiety bipolar disorder schizophrenia
help them fully recover is through a
Grassroots movement but it's got to be a
Grassroots movement based on science
evidence based on putting it all
together so that we can understand very
clearly how exactly do these medications
work why would they reduce symptoms in
the short run and also why should we be
terrified about what we might be doing
to people in the long run with these
very medications